We can compute this maximum regular
estimated by using the EM algorithm.
So in the E-step, we now have to
introduce more hidden variables because
we have more topics.
So our hidden variable Z now, which is
a topic indicator, can take more than
two values.
Specifically, will take a K plus one
values with B denoting the background
and one through K to denote all the K
topics.
So now the E step as you can recall is
augmented data and by predicting the
values of the hidden variable.
So we're going to predict for word
whether the word has come from one of
these K+1 distributions.
This equation allows us to predict the
probability that the word W in Document
D is generated from topic theta
sub j
And the bottom one is the predicted
probability that this word has been
generated from the background.
Note that we use Document D here to
index the word.
Why? Because
Whether a word is from a particular
topic, actually depends on the
document.
Can you see why? Well, it's through the pi.
The pis are tied to each document.
Each document can have a potentially
different pis, right?
The pis will then affect our
prediction, so the pis are here, and
this depends on the document.
And that might give a different guess
of word for word in different
documents, and that's desirable.
In both cases we are using the bayes rule
as I explained, basically assessing the
likelihood of generating word in from
each distribution and is normalized.
What about the M-step?
Well, we may recall
the M step is to take advantage of the
inferred Z values to split the counts
and then collect the right counts to re
estimate parameters.
So in this case we can re estimate our
coverage probability and this is re
estimated based on collecting all
the words in the document.
And that's why we have the count of the
word in document and sum over all the
words.
And then we're going to look at the to
what extent this word belongs to the
topic's theta sub-j, and this part
is our guess from E-step.
This tells us how likely this word is
actually from theta sub-j, and when
we multiply them together we get the
discounted count that's allocated for
topic theta sub-j and we normalize
this over all the topics we get the
distribution over all the topics to
indicate the coverage.
And similarly, the bottom one is to
re-estimate the probability of word for
topic.
In this case we're using exactly the
same count.
You can see this is the same discounted
count, it tells us to what extent we
should allocate this word to
topic theta sub-j.
But the normalization is different
because in this case we are interested
in the word distribution.
So we simply normalize this over all
the words.
This is different.
In contrast, here we normalized among
all the topics.
It would be useful to take a comparison
between the two.
This gives us different distributions
and these tells us
how to improve the parameters?
And as I just explained in both E step
formulas, we have a maximum likelihood
estimator based on the allocated word
counts to
topic theta sub-j.
Now this phenomena is actually general
phenomenon in all the EM algorithms in
the M step, you generate computed
expected count of event based on the
E step result and then you just collect
the relevant counts for a particular
parameter.
and re-estimate with normalizing.
Typically.
So in terms of computation of the EM
algorithm, we can.
Actually, just keep counting various
events and then normalize them.
And when we think in this way, we also
have a more concise way of presenting
the EM algorithm.
It actually helps us better understand
the formulas.
So I'm going to go over this in some
detail.
So as the algorithm, we first
initialize all the unknown parameters
randomly.
In our case we are interested in
all those coverage parameters--
pis--and word distributions, thetas.
And we just randomly normalize them.
This is the initialization step, and
then we will repeat until likelihood
converges.
Now how do we know whether likelihood
converges we're going to compute
likelihood at each step and compare the
current likelihood with the previous likelihood
if it doesn't change much and
we're going to say stop right?
So in each step we can do E step and
M step in the E step we're going to
augment the data by predicting the
hidden variable values.
In this case the hidden variable Z sub
DW indicates whether word in W in D
is from topic or background, an if
it's from a topic which topic?
So if you look at the E step formulas
essentially we're actually normalizing
these counts.
At all, sorry, these are probabilities
of observing the word from each
distribution, so you can see basically
the prediction of word from topic
theta sub-j is based on the
probability of selecting that theta
sub-j as a word distribution to begin to generate
the world multiplied by the probability
of observing the word from that
distribution.
And I said it's proportional to this
because in completing the
implementation of EM algorithm you can just
keep count counter for this quantity
and then in the end you just normalize
it.
So the normalization here is over all
the topics and then you will get a
probability.
Now in the M step we do the same and we
are going to collect these.
Allocated counts for each topic.
And we split words among the topics.
And then we're going to normalize them
in different ways to obtain the
re-estimate.
So, for example, we can normalize among
all the topics to get re estimate of Pi
the coverage.
Or we can renormalize based on the.
For all the words and that would give
us a word distribution.
So it's useful to think of the
algorithm in this way, because when you
implement, you can just use.
Variables to keep track of these
quantities in each case.
And then you just normalize these
variables to make them a distribution.
Now I did not put the constraint for
this one and I intentionally leave this
as exercise for you and you can see
what's the normalizer for this one.
It's of a slightly different form, but
it's essentially the same as the one
that you have seen here.
Namely this one.
So in general, in the implementation of
EM algorithm you will see you accumulated
counts various counts and then you
normalize them.
So to summarize, we introduced the PLSA
model, which is a mixture model with K
unigram language models representing K
topics.
And we also added a predetermined
background language model to help
discover discriminating topics.
Because this background language model
can help attract the common terms.
And,
We show that with maximum likelihood estimator
we can discover topical knowledge from
text data.
In this case PLSA allows us to discover
two things.
One is k-word distributions, each
representing a topic and the other is
the proportion of each topic in each
document.
And such detailed characterization of
coverage of topics in documents can
enable a lot of further analysis.
For example, we can aggregate the
documents in the particular time period
to assess the coverage of a particular
topic in a time period that would allow
us to generate the temporal chains of
topics.
We can also aggregate topics covered in
documents associated with a particular
author, and then we can characterize
the topics written by this author, etc.
And in addition to this, we can also
cluster terms and cluster documents.
In fact, each topic can be regarded as
a cluster, so we already have term
clusters.
And the higher probability words can
be regarded as in belonging to one
cluster.
Represented by the topic.
Similarly documents can be clustered in
the same way.
We can assign a document to the topic
cluster that's covered most in the
document.
So remember pis indicate to what
extent each topic is covered in the
document.
We can assign the document to the topic
cluster that has the highest pi.
And in general, there are many useful
applications of this technique.